Oh, I'm so happy for you
and you're beautiful baby.
Thank you.
And this is the first time
you've been away from your baby.
Yeah, this is the first time I've been away from her.
And she started school this week,
which she's been sending me the cutest little videos
and I feel so.
Oh, there she is.
Oh my gosh.
(Drew laughs)
Babies and doggies.
Oh!
No!
Oh, there's River.
He's been with me for 13 years, many stages of my life.
And then that's our new little puppy, Early,
or we live in England, Early.
That's Early.
Oh, I'm so happy for your life.
I think we have also one other thing in common
that I found out about,
which is our obsession with caffeine.
And you have a favorite coffee, right?
Yes, Irving farm.
I'm obsessed with Irving,
which I try to stay at a hotel
that's close enough to Irving Farm
so that I can go like get outta bed in my pajamas
and go over to Irving Farm
and get a coffee before I see anybody.
Well, we wanted to play a little game with you
if you don't mind.
Oh, sure.
Yeah.
Okay great.
We wanted to put your taste buds to the test.
Yes, I haven't had enough coffee.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Alrighty.
This is good.
One of them is Irving Farms.
My favorite.
If you can answer correctly, no pressure,
I wanted to give everyone in the audience
a beautiful coffee maker that I made.
Those are them right there.
(audience applauding)
Because--
Those are beautiful.
(audience applauding)
I don't know if anyone else--
No pressure.
Feels like Haley and I do,
which is, and I heard it's like your last thought
before you go to bed.
Yeah, I go to bed.
I can't wait to wake up in the morning
'cause I'm like, hmm, coffee.
That's how I am with the tea.
I love this.
Let coffee come fast.
We want to share
in this moment with you guys.
So will you kindly do a taste test?
Okay, so.
I'm nervous.
This is a lot of pressure
'cause those are
I know.
very beautiful.
I know, I'm sorry.
My dad, my family drinks Folgers.
Oh, that's interesting.
One of these are Folgers.
That's weird and random.
I think that one might have been Folgers actually.
I think that might have been what the senses were (laughs).
That was Folgers.
(audience applauding)
Okay, I think it's this one.
Oh my God, Haley, you're absolutely right.
Yeah!
(audience applauding)
Yes.
Am I really right
about this?
You're so right.
That is Irving Farms.
Do you literally, do you wanna take a stab
at what the third one was?
Okay.
Let me try it again.
I am so impressed.
I don't know.
Is it like a Starbucks?
Yeah!
(both screaming)
I can't believe it.
Yes.
And you get to have Drew Barrymore's coffeemaker.
I made those coffee makers with my heart and my mind,
and they're all this advanced technology.
So you will not see the screen display until you touch it.
They're beautiful.
And then when you do,
it will come on
and you can make yourself a beautiful pot of coffee
and join Haley and I in saying cheers
to one's morning,
Cheers.
And having a beautiful day
and joining us us today.
Hope you think of us.
Cheers.
(audience applauding)
I love you.
My dear Haley Bennett, ladies and gentlemen.
"Cyrano" is in theaters starting tomorrow, February 25.
And we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)